the year 1933 and the world around us is
changing for better and For Worse King
Kong amazes movie audiences the 21st
amendment ends prohibition and around
the corner looms a dark period for the
world amidst this backdrop scientists
continue to fill the world with wonders
conceiving of astronomical Marvels and
medical Miracles and as they dive deeper
into the invisible world around us a
rare ciliate makes an appearance and
after an absence of almost 90 years we
found it again
[Music]
we aren't in the business of news here
at Journey to the micro Cosmos but we do
sometimes find something that feels like
it should be breaking news like when
James our master of microscopes manages
to find a microb that hasn't been
spotted since the
1930s that always gets the rest of us on
the journey to the microcosmos team
excited because we know we're about to
see something weird and weird is exactly
what James brought us the organism that
he found is that ovalish character with
a Twisted Tail at one end and that tail
ended up making it really difficult for
James to get other scientists to believe
what he had found but before we get
there let's start with how James managed
to find this microbe to begin with which
really leads us to a question you might
not think about when you're walking
around how old is that
pond now obviously the answer depends on
which Pond you're talking about if you
live in a city like James does the ponds
you stumble across are much more likely
to be on the younger side and that poses
a bit of a conundrum for James in his
hunt for this particular microbial
specialty cilat because when it comes to
finding h hot spots of ciliate diversity
older ponds are much better ciliates can
spread to new locations as cysts which
get carried by the wind or animals from
one spot to another so a pond that has
been around for a while will probably
have welcomed many new residents over
the years building a diverse microscopic
neighborhood in the process there is
this one particular Lake in Warsaw
though that's been a curiously Rich spot
for ciliates which was surprising to
James given how young ponds usually are
in cities but when he looked through
older maps of Warsaw he found that this
Pond had been around for at least 130
years and probably even longer giving it
plenty of time to accumulate more and
more ciliates including rare ones when
James found this organism four years ago
he was so excited to have uncovered what
he was sure was a member of the genus
bra ailum he'd found so so many of them
in this Pond and he wanted to be able to
learn more from an expert so he reached
out to someone who works on this genus
sending an email that included images of
what he had found and mentioned just how
many of them he'd found but when he
heard back the expert simply told him
that the silate he'd found was damaged
that the weird taale wasn't actually a
tale it was just something wrong with
the sample he'd collected and that
response was discouraging especially
given how many other individuals like
this James had found but our master of
microscopes is nothing if not persistent
so he returned to the pond and on his
way he posted about his hunt for a rare
ciliate on Instagram and then he got a
response from the ciliate expert
Professor Hova estaban who has since
become one of james' main collaborators
though at the time they were just
acquaintances Professor estabon asked
James what he was on the hunt for and
when he sent her the picture of the
tailed ciliate it blew her mind she had
never seen anything like it in her long
years of exploring the microcosmos but
she was able to uncover a German paper
from
1933 by a professor JV jelli and when
James looked through the illustrations
in the paper he found his tailed Sil it
it wasn't damaged at all it was just so
rare that the last report of one went
back
decades it was tricky but James was able
to identify the species as bra ailim
catam by looking at specific patterns
where the Cilia Roots into the plasma
membrane these patterns are really hard
to see with a light microscope James was
just able to make out those identifying
details with his it was frustrating
though to try and convince others of
what he'd found even though he kept his
samples in a large tank and kept turning
up more or tailed bra ailum one of the
scientists he talked to insisted that
there was no actual tail that what he
was seeing was maybe some kind of
remnant of how he pipetted his samples
onto the slide that James was stretching
and deforming the cell into forming a
tail-like structure James just rolled
his eyes and made a handheld microscope
to watch the braap film in action in the
tank and there he could see several of
them swimming around on the sediment
that tals very much present without
James's intervention and that means the
bra ailum he found were not damaged they
were just the perfect combination of
weird and rare that does make them hard
to
believe tails are not a common trait
among ciliates and even more strangely
James found that the length of the tail
seemed to vary from Individual to
individual given how rare bra ailm are
it's hard to establish EXA exactly what
the purpose of their tail is but James
has a few ideas one is that the tail
might be involved in helping the
organisms survive in low oxygen areas
increasing the brail's surface area so
they can take in more oxygen so
individuals that live in areas with
lower oxygen concentrations might have a
longer tail but the tail might also help
bra ailum eat because it is lined with
extrusomes which are organel that can be
fired off to paralyze food in this case
we can see the braap film paralyzing
rapers and turning them into food and
here is a well-fed ra ailum stuffed with
[Music]
rapers when James was telling us about
his experience with bofilm called Adam
the thing that stood out to him most was
how challenging it was to convince
people of its existence and how
formative Professor EST On's belief in
what he'd found was she didn't
discourage him instead she hunted
digging through old texts with the same
persistence that James shows with his
old city ponds unfortunately despite
years of encounters the braa filim
seemed to have disappeared from the pond
but who knows maybe they'll turn up
there again or in some distant Pond and
when someone finds it and isn't sure of
what they found we hope they can at
least find this video a letter from a
past microscopist who believes in
them thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us given the fact
that you have just watched this entire
video we're going to go ahead and assume
that you enjoy learning on YouTube well
did you know that you can actually earn
college credit for doing that you see
the company that produces Journey to the
microcosmos also o produces a lot of
other shows and one of those shows is
study hall a channel that lets you start
taking college courses right here on
YouTube Here's how it works you watch
the course videos on the study hall
Channel for free and then you can sign
up for an online college course led by
Arizona State University faculty for
just
$25 and apply what you have learned if
at the end of the course you're happy
with your grade you can pay $400 which
is about a third of the cost of college
credit and now you have three
transferable college credits on your
transcript whether you're trying to
learn new skills earn college credit or
just prove to yourself that you can do
it study hall may help you reach your
goals without the Financial Risk you can
pick between common gened courses like
modern world history human communication
and more on the study hall Channel check
out gudy hall.com or click the link in
the description to learn
more the names on the screen right now
those are our patreon on patrons they're
the people who make it possible for us
to continue on this journey just think
of this when you first heard that a
ciliate had been found that hadn't been
seen in 90 years did you think that it
was our master of microscopes who would
have found it I bet you didn't but it
was and that's one of the reasons I
think what we do here is pretty special
if you want to help us out you can go to
patreon.com/crashcourse
and if you want to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere
nearby